l'inquiétude à présent d'une partie des
habitants de Chanceaux-sur-Choisille un
établissement scolaire privé a choisi de
s'implanter dans un ancien château du
village la fraternité s'impidis une
communauté catholique traditionaliste
devrait gérer l'enseignement des enfants
de la petite section à la troisième un
collectif d'habitants s'est constitué
pour alerter sur les dérives possibles
de cet établissement on en parle avec
notre invité du jour
Catherine geraudie bonjour vous êtes
membre du collectif laïcité chanso alors
expliquez-nous d'abord quelles sont les
motifs de votre inquiétude alors nous
avons constitué ce collectif suite à
l'information par la Nouvelle République
de l'instauration de ce pôle scolaire
intégriste
en mars dernier
nous avons constitué ce collectif sur la
base d'une pétition qui explique que
nous citoyens citoyennes de sensibilité
diverses attachée à la protection de la
jeunesse la défense de l'instruction la
laïcité
[Musique]
qui s'est fait décapiter voilà que son
meurtre par décapitation était moins
graves que le blasphème
et ça ça vous interpelle
je pense que comme tout le monde ça peut
effectivement interpeller ça veut dire
que on confie quand même on confirait
l'enseignement de la jeunesse
dans un cadre où finalement les lois de
Dieu sont au-dessus des valeurs de la
République ce qui est quand même
contradictoire avec même la loi puisque
la loi dont prévoit que ces écoles hors
contrats doivent suivre quand même le
socle commun et dans le socle commun on
a quand même toute une série d'éléments
quand même au minimum sur le fait que
normalement ils doivent par
l'apprentissage expérience garantir les
principes qui comme la liberté de
conscience d'expression la tolérance
réciproque l'égalité notamment entre les
hommes et les femmes alors cette école
elle existe déjà elle a déjà j'allais
dire pignon sur rue à Tours elle va
déménager à Chanceaux-sur-Choisille elle
a donc déjà une autorisation aujourd'hui
pourtant vous alerter la préfète sur
cette établissement qu'est-ce que vous
attendez d'elle alors
d'abord effectivement ça le notre combat
n'a pas qu'une valeur locale il a une
valeur plus générale contre je veux dire
le fait que des groupes scolaires
puissent s'être encadrés par des
intégristes
après
il s'agit quand même d'une volonté
d'expansion par ailleurs sur la commune
de champceaux sur Choisy puisque c'est
un terrain de 22 hectares avec des
enfants oui alors en fait il a été il
avait été évoqué le fait que eux-mêmes
expliquait que ils avaient une volonté
d'accueillir des des gens qui venaient
de Paris d'ailleurs enfin que c'était
qu'ils étaient allés trois dans leur
locaux
aujourd'hui c'est quoi la suite de votre
collectif quels sont les prochaines
actions alors nous avons écrit à la
préfète à plusieurs reprises
nous nous appuyons sur ce sur quoi nous
pouvons nous appuyer c'est à dire la loi
qui lui permet comme Homère et comme aux
procureur de la République et comme au
responsable de l'enseignement de former
opposition à la déclaration d'intention
de donc de ce fameux groupe scolaire
donc vous attendez qu'elle interdise
l'installation de cet établissement tout
à fait merci merci beaucoup le Catherine
Giraud dit d'être venu sur notre plateau